the murder trial of the man accused of
killing Colorado mother
Kelsey Bharath begins today the
multi-state investigation made national
headlines the 29 year-old woman was last
seen in a grocery store with her baby on
Thanksgiving Day last year her body was
never found
Barrett's fiance Patrick Frazee is
charged with her murder
Niki batiste has been covering this
story from the very beginning Niki what
can we expect today Anthony a good
morning jury selection is set to begin
and last a few days at the center of
this trial is crystal Lee a nurse who
was allegedly having an affair with
Patrick Frazee she claims she cleaned up
the murder crime scene because she
wanted to please Frazee and because she
feared him this case really does live or
die on crystal e as prosecutors prepare
their star witness for the murder trial
against Patrick Frazee legal experts say
it may not be a slam-dunk case
University of Colorado law professor I
agree bur there's no body and there's no
murder weapon crystal Lee an Idaho nurse
was allegedly Frazee secret girlfriend
she told authorities Frazee tried to get
her to kill Kelsie Bharath three
different times once with a poisoned
Starbucks Coffee Lee says in the end it
was Frazee who murdered the mother of
his child at Eris home on Thanksgiving
Day by beating her with a baseball bat
but male DNA found at the crime scene
does not match frizzy how would you
describe the physical evidence in this
case so far I would describe the
physical evidence that I know of to be
pretty weak at trial freezies defense
may point the finger at Lee suggesting
she's fabricated parts of her story
before do you think the defense will
paint crystal Lee as a liar they will
absolutely paint crystal Lee as a liar
and in fact there is evidence that
initially she did lie to investigators
she said that she had no idea who
Patrick Frazee or Kelsie Bharath were
after Beth's disappearance investigators
say her cell phone pinged 800 miles from
her home in Woodland Park Colorado near
gooding Idaho
investigators say Lee eventually
admitted she had the phone destroyed it
and she also got rid of Barrett's keys
and a gun all to help Frazee cover his
tracks
why Krystal had it all she'd had it all
Laura
Stutzman lives in Lee's Idaho community
and has known her since she was a
teenager we spoke to her in an interview
for 48 hours
there's no sentence imposed by a judge
that can actually be more harsh than
what her community will put on Krystal
in exchange for her testimony Lee agreed
to plead guilty to evidence tampering
she faces a maximum of three years in
prison but if her story falls apart her
deal is off the table
Frazee has entered a not guilty plea and
faces life in prison if convicted and I
can't help but think about Haley Kelsey
and Patrick now - she is with Kelsey
Barrett's what are they what Nicki what
do they suspect Frazee's motive would be
in this case prosecutors have said they
believe it was actually a custody battle
over Kaylie that they found documents at
Patrick frizzies ranch
that he wanted custody but we don't know
if Kelsey actually was aware where did
you say Kaley was a little girl she is
with Kelsey Barrett's parents because
it's heartbreaking to see the video of
them in the grocery store that
Thanksgiving Day yeah one year ago Nicki
thank you very much